IN THE MEANTIME HAVE GREAT
WEEKEND.
SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER FROM
HERE.
-*-*-*
WHO WHO WELCOME TO HANNITY.
ANOTHER BUSY NEWS NIGHT AND
WE'RE WITNESSING HISTORY IN THE
MAKING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CANNOT, WILL
NOT BE STOPPED.
LET'S MAKE ONE THING PERFECTLY
CLEAR.
NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S AGENDA IS AN
EPIC SUCCESS AN ACCORDING TO
BRAND-NEW ECONOMIC NUMBERS OUT
TODAY, A NEW REPORT, A WHOPPING
266,000 NEW JOBS WERE ADDED IN
THE MONTH OF NOVEMBER.
NOW, THAT INCLUDES 54,000 JOBS
IN MANUFACTURING.
OH, THOSE ARE THE JOBS BARACK
OBAMA SAID WERE NEVER COMING
BACK.
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE NOW DOWN AGAIN
TO 3.5%.
THE LOWEST LEVEL SINCE 1969.
ANOTHER RECORD.
AVERAGE HOURLY EARNINGS ARE UP
3.1%.
EVEN CMBC HOST, CRAZY JIM
KRAMER, HE SAID THE MEDIA MOB
DON'T WANT TO REPORT THESE BUT
THESE ARE THE BEST NUMBERS OF
OUR LIVE.
>> CABLE, CNN, WHAT DO THEY
COVER?
16TH IS POSITIVE ECONOMIC NEWS.
ALL THE REST OF THEM ARE
NEGATIVE SO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE, JOE.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO SAY GOOD
THINGS AND THESE ARE THE BEST
NUMBERS I HAVE EVER SEEN IN MY
LIFE.
>> IT CAN'T LAST FOREVER UNLESS
IT'S A PARTICIPATION RATE.
>> IT HAS TO GO UP, JOE, BECAUSE
WHEN WE WIN THE TRADE WAR WHICH
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO WIN,
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PUT
JOBS HERE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO.
IN THE END THE CHINESE HAVE TO
PUT JOBS HERE.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING, JOE, I
CAN'T -- IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHETHER YOU HATE HIM OR LIKE
HIM, THESE ARE REAL NUMBERS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
THANK GOD.
>> TUCKER: AMERICA'S ECONOMY IS
BOOMING LIKE NEVER BEFORE BUT
THIS IS NOT A WORLDWIDE TREND.
NOT AT ALL.
IN FACT, UNDER THE FAR LEFT
LEADERSHIP OF THAT TWO-FACED
TRUDEAU OUR FRIENDS TO THE NORTH
IN CANADA THEIR ECONOMY IS
DECLINING IN A MASSIVE WAY.
LOOK AT THIS.
IN NOVEMBER CANADA LOST 71,000
JOBS.
THE BIGGEST DROP SINCE 2009.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THERE
JUMPED TO NEARLY 6%.
NOW, TRUDEAU, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
TAKE NOTE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE LOWERED
TAXES IN THIS COUNTRY.
GOT RID OF BURDENSOME
REGULATION.
FOUGHT FOR BETTER TRADE DEALS.
AND EMPOWERED AMERICA AND ITS
ENERGY SECTOR.
WE'RE NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
75 YEARS A NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY.
AND BY THE WAY, NOW CANADA,
YOU'RE SUFFERING.
THIS ECONOMY IN AMERICA IS THE
ENVY OF THE WORLD.
BY THE WAY, IF AS I RADICAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRAT RIGHT NOW, I
THINK I WOULD BE A LITTLE
NERVOUS ABOUT ELECTION 2020.
PEACE AND PROSPERITY
PEACE AND PROSTYRITY
PEACE AND PROSTY.ITY
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE NOTHING
FOR THREE YEARS EXCEPT HATE
DONALD TRUMP AND THEIR WILD
SOCIALIST FANTASY.
NEW GREEN DEAL, $52 TRILLION.
MEDICARE FOR ALL BUT NO PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
NOTHING BUT BASELESS, WHAT, AN
IMPEACHMENT SHAR RAY.
MORE CONSPIRACY THEORIES, MORE
LIE.
YOU'VE GOT THREE OF THE MOST
CORRUPT DISHONEST POLITICIANS IN
THE SWAMP OF WASHINGTON.
BY THE WAY, CIRCUS, THAT'S
WHAT'S DRAINING THE SWAMP LOOKS
LIKE.
THEY DON'T LIKE BEING DRAINED
AND EXPOSED, SWAMP
YEAR-TO-DATETURES AND THE
DEMOCRATIC FRONTRUNNER, WOW!
WHAT A BAD WEEK FOR SLEEPY
CREEPY UNCLE JOE.
THIS HAS BEEN A TRAIN WRECK FOR
THE 77-YEAR-OLD CANDIDATE WHO
ALREADY HAD A LOT OF BAGGAGE.
TODAY HE SUGGESTED HIS CAMPAIGN
COULD ATTRACT YOUNGER VOTERS
BECAUSE HE'S NOT AS OLD AS
BERNIE SANDERS.
THERE IS A CAMPAIGN SLOGAN.
THE NO MALARKEY TOUR.
NOBODY UNDER 90 KNOWS WHAT
MALARKEY MEANS.
ON THE SAME DAY AS THE MONSTER
JOBS REPORT HE PREDICTED A
RECESSION.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, YOU HAVE TO
ACTUALLY, TO GET YOUR POWER BACK
YOU HAVE TO PRAY THE ECONOMY
GOES DOWN AND AMERICANS GET
HURT.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO BE IN THAT
POSITION IF AS I POLITICIAN.
HE ALSO PROMISED, HE WOULD NEVER
BREAK A PROMISE.
REALLY?
HE EVEN PICKED A FIGHT WITH HIS
PARTY'S MORAL LEADER, YES,
SOCIALIST, LEADER, SQUAD LEADER,
AOC.
>> THE PARTY IS NOT THERE.
THE PARTY IS NOT THERE AT ALL.
>> SOME IN YOUR PARTY IS.
>> BUT THE NUMBERS AREN'T THERE.
>> YOU GUYS GOT IT ALL WRONG
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
>> IT'S JUST BAD JUDGMENT.
Y'ALL THOUGHT WHAT HAPPENED WAS,
THE PARTY MOVED EXTREMELY TO THE
LEFT.
AFTER HILLARY.
AOC WAS THE NEW PARTY.
SHE'S A BRIGHT AND WONDERFUL
PERSON BUT WHERE IS THE PARTY?
COME ON, MAN.
WHO WHO NOW, ALL OF THIS PALES
IN COMPARISON TO WHAT WE SAW
YESTERDAY.
BIDEN HAD A FULL-BLOWN PUBLIC
MELTDOWN.
WHY?
BECAUSE AN 83-YEAR-OLD IOWA
VOTER DARED TO ASK THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION THAT THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA WOULD NEVER ASK.
THAT WOULD BE ABOUT THE QUID AND
THE PRO AND THE QUO WITH JOE AND
HUNTER, AND BARISMA HOLDINGS.
IT'S A SERIOUS SCANDAL, MOB IS
IGNORING IT, WE TELL YOU THE
TRUTH.
IT DESERVES ANSWERS.
WE DESERVE ANSWERS.
HE LEVERAGED A BILLION OF OUR
DOLLARS, ONE BILLION.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
UNLESS YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCED SON.
IF YOU FIRE HIM YOU GET THE
BILLION.
THEY FIRED HIM.
JOE ACTUALLY CALLED OUT THE
VOTER.
WHAT DID HE CALL HIM?
FAT AND STUPID AND OLD, AND HE
SAID, HEY, MAN, HEY JACK, YOU
WANT TO HAVE A PUSHUP CONTEST?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IS THAT YOUR SON OVER THERE?
--
[INAUDIBLE]
>> YOU'RE SELLING EXCESS TO THE
PRESIDENT JUST LIKE HE WAS.
>> YOU'RE A DAM LIAR, MAN.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
(INAUDIBLE)
>> I'M NOT SAI
>> I'M NOT SEDENTARY.
THE REASON I'M RUNNING IS I'VE
BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME, IF YOU
WANT TO -- LET'S DO PUSHUPS,
RUN, LET'S DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO DO.
NO ONE HAS SAID MY SON HAS DONE
ANYTHING WRONG AND I DID NOT ON
ANY OCCASION, AND NO ONE HAS
EVER SAID THAT.
>> I DIDN'T SAY YOU WERE DOING
ANYTHING WRONG.
I SET UP MY SON TO WORK IN AN
AUTO COMPANY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT YOU SAID?
GET YOUR WORDS STRAIGHT, JACK.
>> YOU DON'T HEAR THAT ON MSNBC.
>> LOOK, HERE'S THE DEAL.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE ANY BACKBONE
IN THE CONTEST.
[BOOS]
>> ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR
YOU.
>> I KNEW YOU WOULDN'T.
YOU'RE TOO OLD TO VOTE FOR ME.
YOU'RE TOO OLD TO VOTE FOR M .
HANNITY: JOE IS CLEARLY
AGITATED.
YOU CAN'T FOOL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ALTHOUGH THE VOTER YOU
JUST SAW WAS ANGRILY CONFRONTED.
THIS IS AFTER THE TOWN HALL BY A
BIDEN SUPPORTER.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHY DON'T YOU JUST GET OUT OF
HERE.
[ BLEEP ]
[INAUDIBLE]
HANNITY: THESE BIDEN PEOPLE ARE
ANGRY.
THE SWAMP, THE SEWER, MOB, THEY
HATE TO BE CHALLENGED.
THIS ISN'T GOING AWAY.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET IT GO AWAY.
IT'S BIG, IF JOE BIDEN WINS HIS
PARTY NOMINATION.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE HIS REAL UKRAINIAN QUID
PRO QUO WOULD BE A MAJOR TOPIC
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND IN A CANDID
MOMENT EVEN BLOOMBERG ADMITTED
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD DESTROY
BIDEN AND EVERY OTHER DEMOCRAT
IN THE UPCOMING ELECTION.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE MAYOR HAS TO
SAY.
>> I WATCH AND I SAID WE CAN'T
HAVE ANOTHER FOUR YEARS OF THIS
AND I WATCHED ALL THE CANDIDATES
AND I JUST THOUGHT TO MYSELF,
DONALD TRUMP WOULD EAT THEM UP.
>> YOU THINK ALL OF THE
CANDIDATES WHO ARE RUNNING
TODAY, HE WOULD EAT THEM UP?
>> LET ME REPHRASE IT.
I THINK THAT I WOULD DO THE BEST
JOB OF COMPETING WITH HIM AND
BEATING HIM.
HANNITY: NO, YOU SAID YOU WOULD
EAT HIM UP.
LET'S RECAP, 2020 DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE WEAK.
THEY ARE ANGRY.
THEY ARE UNHINGED, AND THE TRUMP
ECONOMY IS SOARING.
OH, BY THE WAY, THE ISIS
CALIPHATE IN SYRIA HAS BEEN
DEFEATED, AND -- THEY JUST
ANNOUNCED THEY AREN'T GOING TO
APPEARANCE IN THESE SHAM
PROCEEDINGS.
ON WEDNESDAY DURING HIS VERY
FIRST HEARING, JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN, THE NUTTY NADLER, HE
COULDN'T EVEN STAY AWAY.
LOOK AT THIS.
HE CAN'T STAY AWAKE.
HE HAS ALL OF THESE IVORY TOWER
PROFESSORS LECTURING AMERICANS,
WE, THE SMELLY WAL-MART --
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES, THOSE
OF US WHO BELIEVE IN GOD, WE
CLING TO OUR BIBLES, SECOND
AMENDMENT, GUILTY AS CHARGED.
HE COULDN'T STAY AWAY AS HIS OWN
WITNESSES DRONE ON AND ON ABOUT
THE VIRTUES OF IMPEACHMENT, LED
BY THE GUY WHO THOUGHT TRUMP
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED BECAUSE HE
TWEETED OUT THE WORDS FAKE AND
NEWS, WHICH IS TOTALLY TRUE.
NUTTY NADLER, I'M SURE YOU
WEREN'T THE ONLY ONE SLEEPING,
ON THURSDAY, AFTER ONLY ONE
HEARING, REMEMBER, WE HAD THE
SCHIFF SHOW, IT WAS A SCHIFF
SHOW, WHEN THAT HAPPENED, WE
HAD, OH, ALL THESE WITNESSES.
NOT ONE OF THEM, WAIT A MINUTE,
ONLY ONE.
THEY WERE EITHER HEARSAY
WITNESSES OR OPINION WITNESSES.
NOW WE HAVE THREE OF THESE
PROFESSORS, THEY WITNESS
NOTHING.
THE ONLY ONE WITNESS WE HAVE IS
A GUY BY THE NAME OF AMBASSADOR
SONDLAND.
I ASKED THE PRESIDENT WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO RELEASE THE MONEY?
NOTHING.
AFTER THE THREE DISASTROUS
ACADEMICS, LET'S GO FULL SPEED
AHEAD WITH IMPEACHMENT.
ON WHAT EVIDENCE?
THIS IS THE SAME PELOSI WHO
RAILED AGAINST THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS IN THE 1990s.
IN FACT, SHE ACCUSED REPUBLICANS
OF IMPEACHING BILL CLINTON
MERELY BECAUSE THEY HATED HIM.
KEN STARR DID IDENTIFIED 11
SPECIFIC FELONIES AND CLINTON
DID LOSE HIS LAW LICENSE AND HE
PAID HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO PAULA JONES, BUT THAT
WAS THEN.
FULL HYPOCRISY ON DISPLAY.
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> I DON'T HATE ANYBODY.
I DON'T HATE ANYBODY.
NOT ANYBODY IN THE WORLD.
AS A CATHOLIC, I RESENT YOU
USING THE WORD HATE IN A
SENTENCE THAT ADDRESSES ME.
>> WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE THE
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE ARE
PARALYZED WITH HATRED.
OF PRESIDENT CLINTON AND UNTIL
THE REPUBLICANS FREE THEMSELVES
OF THIS HATRED OUR COUNTRY WILL
SUFFER.
HANNITY: THE COUNTRY IS
SUFFERING NOW.
THERE IS NOTHING HERE.
THE LEVEL OF HYPOCRISY IS
BREATHTAKING.
TOTALLY UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU HAVE TO BIFURCATE YOUR
BRAIN.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT RUSSIA
INTERFERENCE, YOU DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE DIRTY DOSSIER, CARE
ABOUT OBSTRUCTION BUT NOT THE
SUBPOENAED EMAILS, OH, YOU CARE
ABOUT ME, TOO, I BELIEVE, BUT
YOU DON'T SAY A WORD ABOUT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IN THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA.
REALLY?
WHAT A BUNCH OF HYPOCRITES.
WHAT ABOUT THE UKRAINIAN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
SURE, RUSSIA INTERFERED, GUILTY.
NUNES TOLD US WHAT HAPPENED IN
2014.
IT HAPPENED.
YOU'RE NOW WATCHING, IT
ENCAPSULATE TODAY MODERN RADICAL
EXTREME DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND, OF
COURSE, YES, THE OFFICIAL PRESS
OFFICE KNOWN AS THE MEDIA MOB,
STATE RUN TV.
THEY ARE SO CORRUPTED BY THEIR
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE AND HATE, IT'S A
PSYCHOSIS.
NOTHING ELSE MATTERS.
TRUTH, LOGIC, REASON, COMMON
SENSE, EVEN AN IMPROVING
ECONOMY.
HELPING THE LIVES OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NONE OF THAT MATTERS TO THEM AND
IT HAPPENED IN SPITE OF THEM